hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 8
recap and review titled bagman episode 8
has the distinction of not being my
favorite episode of the series or even
the season but still manages to be just
about perfect in every way in truth it
feels more like a breaking bad episode
which is in no way a bad thing and for
that reason I'm sure it will go down as
a fan favorite and the better call Saul
fandom what stands out most to me about
this is that director Vince Gilligan and
company are able to make it feel so
tense and ribbiting even though we know
there's zero chance that Mike or Jimmy
might die as far as what actually
happens 5:08 is a really simple
installment Jimmy has given the task to
be the bagman through no fault of his
own he gets ambushed by rivals of the
Salamanca's Mike swoops in with the
crucial save and then they have to make
their way out of the desert one member
of the attack team escapes after firing
a volley of shots that disable Mike's
truck
Jimmy's trademark Suzuki esteem breaks
down shortly after they leave the scene
so they have to head back on foot
staying off the road to avoid the bad
guy who got away it's two guys who we
know will make it out against the
elements but it still turns out to be
great because of the details and the
performances the episode starts out in
the Salamanca family warehouse that has
an amazing collection of classic cars
and a humongous stash of hundred dollar
bills the cousins make their return
after heading south in season 4 to pick
up the seven million dollars that lalo
needs for his bail I really like that
their bags had this compression mode to
make them more stylish when they're
empty and the fact that the seven
million dollars wasn't enough to even
make a dent in what's sitting there
after they leave we catch up with Lalo
in the interview room reading a
newspaper he sees the article about the
los Pollos hermanos fire which puts him
in a great mood and he proceeds to
explain what he needs Jimmy to do for
him at first Jimmy tries to get out of
picking up the money and in a somewhat
surprising turn Lalo seems to let him
off the hook maybe he was wrong maybe
mr. Goodman isn't the right choice for
the job
no big deal Jimmy makes it to the door
as Lalo sits there looking like he's
moved on completely but instead of
passing through it he hath coughs
$100,000 they end up agreeing on that
number and things are set in motion in
light of their new honesty policy
Jimmy is compelled to tell his wife that
he's officially on his way to becoming a
friend of the cartel and lay out what
that entails he tries to minimize things
but she's not swayed the idea of him
picking up the money frightens her for
good reason and where in the past she
might have just reluctantly said okay
and let it go he or she lets her
feelings be known she says I don't like
this I don't want you to do it we watch
as he gives her a hug to try to make her
feel better and the looks on their faces
tell us that it isn't effective Jimmy
doesn't believe in himself and Kim's
mind appears to already be somewhere
else it was at this moment that my fears
that my guests that Kim might be the one
to visit Lalo in jail which I mentioned
in my preview video for this episode
started to feel all too real after that
we head to the desert where Jimmy finds
himself face to face with the cousins
they drop off the money without speaking
a word which is a great choice that
shows that saul goodman's powers are
useless in situations where the other
side won't engage in conversation having
secured the dough Jimmy drives off and
delivers a great comedic performance as
he tries to cobble together a version of
99 bottles of beer about the money that
he's now transporting things go south
quickly as the Jeep tails him and the
ambush unfolds
Jimmy has no choice but to give up the
money and to his horror the leader gives
the order to kill him at the last second
a sniper bullet kills his would-be
executioner leaving a spray of his blood
on his shirt and a hectic scene there
taking out one by one
and then we see his savior pull up in a
pickup truck they went to some lengths
to disguise the identity as the sniper
approached considering we knew of Mike's
background and of his buying a sniper
rifle back in season 2 it was pretty
obvious it would be him but the way it
was shot it wouldn't let the viewer be
sure until they actually revealed it
this was Mike operating at the top of
his game which is a nice room
finder of the character we know and love
from Breaking Bad since he didn't know
this was going to happen he came by
himself though and even a badass of his
stature runs into the snag of missing
the last guy as mentioned that guy gets
away after firing the shots that take
out Mike's truck and that means that
they have to take the esteem because
it's the only option they have as Mike
takes control of the situation for Jimmy
who's in shock it gives us a moment to
appreciate just how things will never be
the same for him they underline that
idea when the esteem breaks down we
watch as they push it off the road into
a ditch
stopping to grab the world's second best
lawyer again mugged from under the sea
only to find that it too has become a
casualty of the ambush it's not very
subtle Jimmy's leaving parts of himself
in the desert and things that were
uniquely Jimmy are giving way to things
that will define Saul with that out of
the way they strike out into the desert
Jimmy is uncharacteristically quiet
after witnessing the shootout and Mike
well he's Mike he's not exactly a Chatty
Cathy but that doesn't mean this journey
isn't eventful the focus is mostly on
Jimmy and his ever intensifying
transformation into Saul but Mike
actually delivers one of the most
emotional moments at a low point when
Jimmy asks what's it for Mike says I
have people waiting for me they don't
know what I do they never will they're
protected but I do what I do so they can
have a better life and if I live or if I
die it really doesn't make a difference
to me as long as they have what they
need so when it's my time to go I will
go knowing I did everything I could for
them it's a powerful scene with great
delivery by Jonathan banks and given
what we know about how things turn out
for Mike trying to get his money to
Kaylee it really hits home as moving as
it is it's not the thing that gets Jimmy
up off the ground that turns out to be
the return of the truck of the guy who
got away Jimmy gets up wraps a space
blanket around him so that there's no
way you can miss him out there in the
Sun and he heads towards the road for a
second it felt like he was giving up and
that Mike would have to save him for a
second time but
as he's going he tells Mike to get ready
his plan is to draw the driver to him so
that Mike can take him out he'll play
decoy and if things go right they'll be
in an air-conditioned Bronco sipping
ice-cold water on the way into town this
makes for an intense scene where Mike
finally hits the driver with the second
shot which happens to be in the nick of
time since Jimmy appears to be too
exhausted to get out of the way if the
shot would have miss turns out there
won't be any aircon since the crash is
such that there isn't a chance they'll
be driving away right down to tires
being left behind on the road as Mike
was approaching the vehicle I was
thinking well at least I'll probably get
some water out of the deal and it's like
the writers could hear what I was
thinking when he pulls out the crust and
empty water jug we cut the Jimmy sitting
with his head in his hands a man with
very little left in his reserves he
finally takes the Davis and main bottle
that's filled with his pee it's been
tied around his shoulder for the entire
episode practically at this point and he
takes a long pull when urine urine and
with that he gets up to continue walking
as Saul Goodman an official friend of
the cartel the final shot is of a space
blanket laying on the road we see Mike
step on it as they leave it behind and
the episode ends speaking of the space
blanket I skipped over the other big
conversation in the desert where the
blanket was introduced I wanted to save
that to the end because it ties in with
the Kim storyline which is the real
tragedy of this episode Jimmy let it
slip that Kim would be worried when he
doesn't return home because she knows
why he came out to the desert in the
first place this sets off the alarm
bells for Mike who doesn't know Kim and
thinks she might tell someone about the
situation as viewers we know Kim is
smarter than that and really doesn't
have anyone to tell if you think about
it no family no close friends no
co-workers she confides in and enough
sense either way not to contact the
police
unfortunately this turns out to leave
her few options on what to do when Jimmy
doesn't come home and that leads her to
deciding to go see the client that sent
him to pick up the money no Kim no I
don't
this I don't want you to do it she did
it though and Lalo now knows she exists
he also knows she's no dummy after he
gets the opportunity to size her up in
person and he knows she's a lawyer which
he could surely use to his advantage it
is the worst case scenario and the only
bright spot is how good Tony Dalton is
at playing this character in Lalo
Salamanca as he's internalizing all the
ways things shifted in his favor like
him coming to see him he essentially
brushes her concerns aside and refuses
to help her by telling her where he sent
Jimmy to make the pickup he says it's
pointless because if he's alive he'll
show kim follows with and if he's but
can't say the words out loud it's a
crushing thought for her and she
realizes that taking this risk doesn't
pay off at all for her there's this shot
with Lalo walking out the door that says
it all Kim locked in her thoughts with
Lalo feeling completely at ease it feels
like a beginning rather than a chance
encounter and that feels all kinds of
wrong to me after they had their
discussion about Kim where Mike explains
correctly the Jimmy that his wife is now
in the game he says he can't make a fire
and he offers Jimmy a space blanket Mike
wouldn't know it but this is something
that Jimmy associates with his brother
Chuck he won't take it and possibly it's
more like he can't take it it's a symbol
of all the problems he had with Chuck
and how terribly everything turned out
being cold as a small price to pay to
not have to revisit thinking about that
and that's pretty much it for all the
major things that happen it is a great
looking episode there's one shot in
particular where they're walking across
the desert and the sky is in time-lapse
but they're moving isn't it's really a
cool looking shot Vince Gilligan of
course did direct this he spent quite a
lot of time out in the desert and does a
really good job there really is so much
to like about this episode we don't
really veer off into the side stories we
don't see anything having to do with Gus
or nacho or any of the other characters
we focus primarily on Jimmy and Mike Bob
Odenkirk and Jonathan banks both deliver
outstanding performances it's not like
you would expect last but whether each
new episode
actors always find a way to remind us
just how good they can be at the end of
the day the Kim stuff is just a bummer
it's not like we don't know that
something's gonna happen to her it's
inevitable and at the same time we've
been wanting these stories that all come
together but seeing it play out is
really kind of heavy and I just don't
want to see something bad happen to this
character it's silly maybe but it's the
truth
there's so many great little details as
they move through the desert as well
like the Davis and main bottle the fact
that it ends with him drinking his own
urine just so he can keep going he may
be a friend of the cartel now and I
imagine he's probably going to be buying
himself a new Cadillac with that hundred
thousand dollars but he certainly earned
it all the way some other random
thoughts the action sequence of the
ambush was executed flawlessly
I don't watch better call Saul for the
intense action sequences but this was
really put together well I thought Kim's
decision to go seal all of socks but how
can we expect her to be okay with doing
nothing at the same time it seems like
the real reason she didn't want to me to
be the bagman was because she sensed his
life could be in danger that's fair that
makes sense
she can put up with a lot but she can't
put up with him putting his own life in
jeopardy this isn't a scam he's doing
it's a real interaction with criminals
and that's the kind of thing that has
life or death consequences when the
episode was funny it was funny the song
in the car was hilarious to watch and I
couldn't help but laugh when we saw
Jimmy pouring the water on that spot
that he had on his shoe
of course that's gonna be foreshadowing
of him running out and then the whole
Davison main bottle I mean he's got this
thing filled up with his pee he's got it
tied with his tie around his shoulder
it's obvious that eventually he's gonna
have to drink it and the whole thing
it's printed with Davis and main so it
reminds you of all the crazy stuff he
was doing when he worked there to try to
get fired so that he could keep his
bonus lots of little callbacks and stuff
- it was cool when Mike grabbed the gas
cap before they went down the road and
explained how he knew where Jimmy was
and it was a nice callback to earlier
seasons whenever he was playing games
with Gus and when it was sad it was sad
not just the realization that Kim is now
officially in the game but the whole
space blanket scene and Jimmy refusing
to take it knowing what that symbolizes
knowing that part of Jimmy's problem
right now as he's never been able to
sort out his feelings in the wake of his
brother's death we saw that bubble up to
the surface in the last episode and we
know that he still carries that with him
so I'm gonna leave it there let me know
in the comments what you think were you
super pumped up about this
do you like the Breaking Bad style
episode better than what we've been
seeing or what did you think we only got
two episodes left I will be making a
second video this week about the trailer
so make sure you come back for that let
me know what you want to see in those
last two episodes how have your thoughts
changed what are you looking forward to
what are you fearing please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon